und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian Sievers guten Abend
in allen das wirklich aufrüttelnde an
der miesen Wirtschaftslage in
Deutschland ist dass man die Situation
nicht einfach auf weltweite
Herausforderungen schieben kann es ist
eben nicht so dass sie überall gerade
mit einem globalen Niedergang kämpfen
vieles von dem was die Unternehmen in
Deutschland umtreibt ist hausgemacht es
sind speziell deutsche Versäumnisse die
dringend aufgeholt gehören Energiepreise
Bürokratie Digitalisierung
klingende Namen aus dem
marketing-baukasten für diverse Projekte
werden allein nicht reichen die
Bundesregierung hat heute ein ganzes
Paket vorgestellt womit die Koalition
dieses Land voranbringen will und wie
das ankommt zeigt Andreas
ich habe ein erste-hilfe-kabel dabei
sagt die Bildungsministerin und das
passt nicht nur zum Handy des
Arbeitsministers sondern auch zum
angestrebten Zweck dieser Klausur die
Sitzung hat noch nicht mal angefangen
schon kommt Minister Heil mit der
Digitalisierung voran und Schweizer
taschenwärme Ministerin Schweizer
Taschenmesser mit der Teambildung
auch am zweiten Tag der
Regierungsklausur verspricht die Ampel
Koalition sich zu bessern den vielfach
geäußerten wunschgeräuschloser zu
regieren in der zweiten Hälfte der
Wahlperiode zu erfüllen wir werden
Hämmern und Klopfen aber mit
Schalldämpfer
das soll ja nicht mehr gehört werden
ihren Beschluss die Wirtschaft mit
Steuererleichterungen in Höhe von 7
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr zu entlasten
hat das Team Scholz gestern tatsächlich
geräuscharm zusammengeklopft aber für
das größte Problem die zu hohen Energie
Preise findet die Ampel keine gemeinsame
Lösung Finanzminister Lindner ist gegen
einen subventionierten
industriestrompreis Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck dafür Scholz ist dagegen auch
weil die EU-Kommission bremst es hämmert
und klopft aber mit Schalldämpfer also
natürlich gibt es da einen fortführen
gesprächskanal und
mir ist jetzt nicht zu sagen heute
jedenfalls nicht
kommt ihr alle raus zur Inszenierung von
Meseberg gehört dass die scholzregierung
nicht nur Beschlüsse verkündet sondern
die wirksamsten Beschlüsse aller Zeiten
das heute beschlossene Bürokratie
abbaugesetz werde den Unternehmen Kosten
von 2,3 Milliarden Euro ersparen so viel
habe noch keine Koalition davor
geschafft
wir sind eine Regierung wo
gehämmert geschraubt wird das führt zu
Geräuschen wie sie schon festgestellt
haben aber es kommt eben auch was raus
es kommt aber eben manchmal auch nichts
raus obwohl alle Welt wartet und drängt
die Entscheidung ob Deutschland der
Ukraine Marschflugkörper vom Typ Taurus
liefert oder nicht findet die FDP
überfällig die Grünen sagen ist zähle
jeder Tag nur Scholz entscheidet dass er
noch nicht entscheidet das Kanzlers
Regierung soll besser schneller und
geräuschempfindlicher werden er selbst
bleibt wie er ist
es gibt einiges was in Deutschland
aktuell schwer zusammenpasst schnelle
Entscheidungen die nötig wären aber
Behörden die auf Nummer sicher gehen
Infrastruktur die in die Zukunft weisen
muss und ein marodes Schienennetz dafür
LKW Colonnen auf überlasteten Autobahnen
Firmen die händeringend Nachwuchs suchen
und junge Leute die keinen
Ausbildungsplatz finden vor dem
Hintergrund des Fachkräftemangels aller
Orten ein Widerspruch den wir uns nicht
leisten können da finden Angebot und
Nachfrage nicht zusammen und das hat
gravierende Folgen wie Luisa Ruben zeigt
wir fangen jetzt mal ein Angebot zu
machen es ist anders madanis
erst mit 28 eine Stelle als Facility
Manager bei einem Putzservice
den Job den du hier hast was bedeutet
denn hier also er bedeutet mir sehr viel
da ich hier sehr viele Perspektiven habe
neue Perspektiven vor allem die bekommt
der von seinem neuen Chef der ihm mehr
zutraut und auch nach Feierabend neues
erklärt man muss natürlich sich mehr
Zeit nehmen wie jetzt eine fertige
Fachkraft
aber das ist der Job das gehört dazu und
es wird sich nicht ändern in der Zukunft
Annas Madani hat keine Berufsausbildung
sowie mehr als 2,6 Millionen Menschen
zwischen 20 und Mitte 30 so viele wie
nie mit einem Hauptschulabschluss
handelt er sich von Job zu Job verdient
jetzt ca 2000 € netto
meine Rechnung zu zahlen und es war
immer ja liebe arbeiten gehen anstatt
jetzt ein Ausbildung anzufangen und
Arbeit gibt es für ungelernte Kräfte
gerade genug langfristig aber werden
Fachkräfte fehlen mehr als 220.000
Ausbildungsstellen bleiben diesen Sommer
unbesetzt vor allem für die körperlich
anstrengenden Berufe
seit Jahren finden Sie bei der Firma
Rebstock Raumdesign niemanden der
Parkettleger werden möchte und sorgen
sich um die Zukunft des Betriebs
dann wird irgendwann die Luft dünn und
im freien Markt es gibt ja keine Leute
also bescheiden so viel Werbung und also
von gelernten Leuten ist keine Chance
langfristig wird sich rächen das
einfache Jobs für einige gerade
attraktiver sind und dafür
Ausbildungsplätze frei bleiben
Fachkräfte die Zeichen sich dadurch aus
dass sie nachhaltige Kompetenzen und
Qualifizierungen haben und das kann man
in einem nur Arbeitsverhältnis nicht
entwickeln deshalb ist es wichtig dass
man eine grundlegende Qualifikation in
einem Beruf mitbringt der muss nur dann
dazu führt dass man im Beruf gut ist
sondern dass man auch eine Grundlage hat
den Beruf zu wechseln
junge Menschen fühlen sich verloren
wissen nicht welchen Beruf sie überhaupt
lernen wollen das stellen sie auch im
Jugendhaus Fasanenhof in Stuttgart fest
Anas Madani kommt häufig her neuerdings
gibt es für berufsfragen eine
Sprechstunde ja wird dann auch gefragt
hey was kannst du gut oder was bist du
für einer und dann kommt so erstmal
nichts
und dann über so ein praktisches
Arbeiten aus unterschiedlichen Dingen
kann man doch bei sich was findet was
Gutes was man kann wo man was beitragen
kann zur Gesellschaft auch anders Madani
fragt sich manchmal wohin sein Berufsweg
noch führt aber nicht doch noch eine
Ausbildung machen sollte viele
Arbeitgeber denken okay der hat nichts
drauf deswegen brauche ich einfach auf
dem Papier als Beweis sein der anders
hat drei Jahre durchgebissen und ähm hat
seinen Abschluss gemacht erstmal freut
er sich jetzt aber über den festen Job
und will weiter Geld verdienen auch ohne
Ausbildung
neues vom stellvertretenden bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten jetzt der in der
Affäre um ein widerliches Flugblatt
unter Druck ist neues diesmal von Hubert
Aiwanger selbst er spricht zum ersten
Mal seit bekannt werden der Vorwürfe
dazu vor der Kamera ich bin wieder
Antisemit noch Extremist sondern ich bin
ein Demokrat ich bin ein Menschenfreund
kein Menschen Feind und insofern sage
ich das wirklich dass ich hier für die
letzten Jahrzehnte alle Hände ins Feuer
legen kann und wo sie in Jugendzeiten
hier diskutiert wird wundert mich etwas
aber es ist auf alle Fälle so dass
vielleicht in der Jugendzeit ist eine
oder andere so oder so interpretiert
werden kann wo soll es 15-Jähriger hier
mir vorgeworfen wird aber auf alle Fälle
ich sage seitdem wir Erwachsenenalter
die letzten Jahrzehnte keine Antisemit
keine Extremist sondern ein
Menschenfreund
seitdem Erwachsenenalter kein Antisemit
kein Extremist bedeutet das also davor
möglicherweise schon Stefan Seifert ist
unser Bayern Korrespondent Stefan ist
das jetzt einfach das
Verteidigungsstrategie also Stichwort
Jugendsünde
ja man kann aus dem Statement von heute
zwei Dinge sehr klar herauslesen das
eine ist dass es jetzt sein erstes
kleines Eingeständnis gibt von Hubert
aanger das ist in dessen jugendvorfälle
gegeben hat die jetzt Anlass gegeben
haben für die Vorwürfe die heute im Raum
stehen das ist neu bisher hat Hubert
Aiwanger die Vorwürfe ja relativ
pauschal zurückgewiesen das ist jetzt
zum ersten Mal ein kleines Zugeständnis
dass da irgendetwas war zweitens kann
man herauslesen wie offenbar seine
Verteidigungsstrategie jetzt aussehen
soll das scheint einen Mischung zu
werden aus Jugendsünden einerseits und
Erinnerungslücken andererseits
Jugendsünden insofern als er sagte das
ist alles so lange her ich war 15 16 17
haben wir danach nie wieder etwas zu
Schulden kommen lassen und erinnere uns
Lücken insofern er wurde heute gefragt
in diesem Interview von Reportern was
denn dran sei an den Berichten von
Mitschülern er habe den Hitler groß
gezeigt Judenwitze erzählt oder das Buch
Mein Kampf bei sich getragen darauf hat
Hubert einfacher gesagt das sein absolut
nicht mehr erinnerlich seine Partei die
den Wähler machen diese Strategie
offenbar auch mit stellen sich
geschlossen hinter ihre gaionsfigur am
Abend gab es eine Presseerklärung der
entscheidenden Parteigremien und sie
teilen auch die Auffassung von Hubert
Aiwanger das all das eine schmutzige
Kampagne gegen ihn ist die in politisch
zunichte machen sollen sie stellen sich
geschlossen hinter ihnen haben in den
Kampfmodus geschaltet und wollen die
Landtagswahl hier am 8 Oktober nun auch
zu einer Abstimmung über Hubert awanger
machen interessant was über die Freien
Wähler da sagst Stefan interessant ist
aber natürlich auch wie das Ganze
ankommt bei der CSU dem
Koalitionspartner und dem
Ministerpräsidenten Markus Söder der
will ja 25 Antworten von Aiwanger auf 25
fragen
ja wenn man sich am Abend in der Partei
umhört dann ist völlig klar das was
Hubert Aiwanger heute erklärt hat das
ist nicht der Befreiungsschlag und es
ist auch noch lange nicht die Antwort
auf die 25 sehr ausdifferenzierten
Fragen eins ist heute Abend aber auch
klar wenn die Strategie von Markus Söder
gewesen sein sollte ein Teil zu treiben
zwischen die Partei der Freien Wähler
und ihre Gallionsfigur Hubert awanger
dann scheint das eine Strategie zu sein
die bis jetzt jedenfalls nicht aufgeht
wie sieht's denn zeitlich aus Stefan die
Briefwahl in Bayern läuft an wann ist
denn jetzt mit konkreten Antworten von
Aiwanger zu rechnen bzw wann muss damit
zurechnen sein
ja letzteres ist die Frage denn
eigentlich hat die CSU Hubert alwanger
freigestellt wann er auf die Fragen
antwortet es gibt kein Ultimatum aber
klar ist es ist sowohl in aiwangers
Interesse als auch im Interesse der
gesamten Koalition dass dieses Thema
jetzt möglichst schnell abgeräumt wird
wenn man sich so umhört dann hört man
heraus es dürfte wohl Mitte nächster
Woche werden das passt auch dazu dass es
hier am Donnerstag nächster Woche eine
Sondersitzung des Bayerischen Landtags
gibt hier ist eigentlich noch
Sommerpause aber es wird dann eine
Sondersitzung nur zu diesem Thema geben
also es dürfte Mitte nächster Woche
werden und so lange ist klar bleibt
Hubert Aiwanger ein Minister und
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident auf
Bewährung sagt Stefan Seifert unser
bayern-korresponden Stefan herzlichen
Dank nach München
und jetzt einen Blick in die Welt im
ersten Nachrichten Überblick mit dir
eins die Linksfraktion im Bundestag
verschiebt die Neubesetzung ihre
Führungsspitze die eigentlich für
kommenden Montag geplante Wahl findet
nicht statt das beschlossen die Fraktion
auf ihre Klausurtagung in Berlin nachdem
sich keine Lösung für die Nachfolge des
bisherigen führungslos und Mohammed Ali
abzeichnete hintergrund ist ein Parteien
Teller Streit über den richtigen Kurs
und Erwägung von Sahra Wagenknecht eine
eigene Partei zu gründen
die russische Armee hat erneut mehrere
ukrainische Regionen beschossen sechs
Menschen wurden nach offiziellen Angaben
getötet zweite Opfer starben in der
Hauptstadt Kiew als Trümmer
abgeschossener Raketen auf Gebäude
stürzten mehrere Menschen wurden dabei
verletzt und Moskau meldet unterdessen
Drohnenangriffe auf Gebiete in Russland
vor allem auf den Westen in vier
Transportflugzeuge beschädigt worden
bei einem Treffen der
eu-verteidigungsminister im spanischen
Toledo hat sich der EU-Außenbeauftragte
Borell für weitere Militärhilfen von 20
Milliarden Euro für die Ukraine
ausgesprochen sowie für die Ausweitung
des militärischen Ausbildungsprogramms
für ukrainische Streitkräfte zur Lage im
Niger hieß es man werde die gleiche Art
von Strafmaßnahmen gegen die pochisten
verhängen wie die westafrikanische
Staatengemeinschaft
und auch im zentralafrikanischen Gabun
hat das Militär die Macht übernommen
wenige Tage nach der umstrittenen
Präsidentenwahl Amtsinhaber Bongo wurde
offenbar unter Hausarrest gestellt im
Staatsfernsehen erklärten Offiziere
Bongo habe kein Recht auf eine dritte
Amtszeit sie sprechen von Wahlbetrug und
Korruption
wir bleiben noch einen Moment beim
großen Thema dieser Sendung was alles
gehen müsste in Deutschland aber
irgendwie eben nicht geht und jetzt mal
langsam in Fahrt kommen soll auf Praxen
Patienten Apotheken kommt viel Neues zu
manches schon mit Stichtag in vier
Monaten Karl Lauterbach reiht sich als
Gesundheitsminister in eine illustere
Reihe seiner Vorfahren im Amt ein wenn
er heute die Weichen stellt für eine
schnellere Digitalisierung im
Gesundheitswesen die elektronische
Patientenakte hatte bereits Ministerin
Ulla Schmidt vorgestellt anno 2003 vor
20 Jahren
genau wie beim digitalen Rezept das
Ärzte eigentlich schon längst
verpflichtend ausstellen sollen folgten
aber erstmal Verunsicherung Bedenken und
technische Probleme jetzt soll alles
ganz schnell gehen auch wenn auch Fragen
bleiben Daniel
der Gesundheitsminister hätte des
Kanzlers Mahnung die Erfolge der Ampel
künftig stärker zu betonen wohl gar
nicht gebraucht Karl Lauterbach ließ
sich da auch zurückliegend selten von
übertriebener Schüchternheit Bremsen
bezeichnete etwa die krankenhausreform
schon vorab als Revolution und den
heutigen Aufbruch ins digitale so
verbessern im Prinzip die Versorgung
aber auch die Forschungslandschaft in
Deutschland und zwar auf eine Art und
Weise dass man hier wirklich von einem
dramatischen Durchbruch sprechen kann
Ziel sind also genau genommen zwei durch
Brüche der erste betrifft die Versorgung
im sogenannten digitalgesetz schon ab
Anfang nächsten Jahres soll das digitale
irrezept Standard werden heißt statt
rosa Zettel gibt es einen Code aufs
Handy oder auf die Gesundheitskarte eine
Testphase letztes Jahr wurde abgebrochen
nach Einwänden des
Datenschutzbeauftragten diese
Datenschutzprobleme sind beseitigt und
wir schauen jetzt sehr optimistisch in
die Zukunft dass wir
die Zeit bis zur Umsetzung zum ersten
ersten auch nutzen können um alle Praxen
ideal vorzubereiten ein Jahr später soll
dann für alle gesetzlich Versicherten
die elektronische Patientenakte EPA
vorliegen ein Datensatz den alle Ärzte
eines Patienten einsehen können Ziel
mehr Übersichtlichkeit als früher
dadurch Medikationsfehler vermeiden
Behandlungen verbessern zunächst mal ist
es so dass häufig heute bessere
Therapieentscheidungen daran scheitern
dass die Informationen die notwendig
werden um im Kontext des gesamten
Patienten die richtige Entscheidung zu
treffen einfach nicht vorliegen oder
irgendwo auf Papier vorliegen und
deswegen nicht Einsicht genehm genommen
wird das ist der wesentliche Vorteil
wenn die Daten digital und eben auch
rechtzeitig vorliegen wenn jeder kann
sich verweigern dazu muss man aber
ausdrücklich widersprechen auch das
stört den Datenschützer er hätte eine
aktive Einwilligung bevorzugt
wenn man aber sich auf das Opt-Out also
den Widerspruch festlegt dann müssen
ganz besonders sensible Gesundheitsdaten
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche
psychotherapeutische Diagnosen und
andere von diesem automatischen
einspielen und automatischen
Sichtbarkeit für alle Ärztinnen und
Ärzte ausgeschlossen werden in solch
sensiblen Fällen könnte jeder noch mal
widersprechen betonte Minister er
rechnet damit dass ich am Ende wenige
verweigern und die warnt er natürlich
haben sie dann eine schlechtere
Versorgung weil die Befunde dann bei
Ihnen nicht in der Komplettheit und auch
in der also Geschwindigkeit also in den
Behandlungsprozess einfließen wie das
für andere der Fall ist offen also ob
genug mitmachen für Durchbruch Nummer
eins Nummer zwei soll es in der
Forschung geben ein zweites Gesetz
nämlich soll ermöglichen dass sämtliche
verfügbaren Daten hierfür
pseudonymisiert genutzt werden können
vom datenschutzer hierfür grünes Licht
und der Voraussetzungen
es muss dann nachgewiesen werden für
jeden der das nutzt dass er eine
gemeinwohlorientierte Forschung betreibt
dass er die entsprechenden Schritte für
die Sicherheit dieser Daten
gewährleistet dann muss an solcher
Zugang auch möglich sein wir alle wollen
die Erkenntnisse für Behandlung und neue
Medikamente derzeit sei Deutschland da
noch Entwicklungsland erklärte
Lauterbach jüngst das neue Gesetz aus
seinem Haus aber könne dieses
Entwicklungsland nun an die Weltspitze
heranführen
ausgebaut werden soll auch die
tele-medizin die Ärzte und Patienten
zusammenbringt auch wenn beide nicht am
selben Ort sind das kann eine Chance
sein gerade für ländliche Gegenden oder
für kleinere Krankenhäuser mehr dazu von
Jan Meyer mit einem Beispiel aus
Brandenburg
ich denke in dieser Region sehen wir die
Metastase
der Krebs ist noch da eine Operation hat
der Patient bereits hinter sich nun muss
wohl eine Chemotherapie Folgen Oberarzt
brieselmann holt noch die Meinung eines
Spezialisten in Cottbus ein der per
Telefon die Ultraschalluntersuchung mit
verfolgt man hat über diesen Weg die
Möglichkeit Kollegen die
es noch deutlich besser können als einer
selbst beziehungsweise es anders können
immer wieder um Rat und Hilfe zu bitten
und damit auch selber kleine Kniffe die
man sonst sich nicht an eigenen Würde
nahtlos anzueignen der Patient erhält
die Chemotherapie in Guben und spart
sich den Weg nach Cottbus das Naemi
wilke-stift schickt Kranke dorthin nur
für aufwendige Operationen
Brandenburgs größtes Krankenhaus mit
seinen modernen Operation zählen
profitiert von der Vor- und Nachsorge
der Patienten in kleinen Häusern wie dem
in Guben
wir sind nicht dafür ausgelegt dass wir
alle Patienten selber betreuen könnten
dafür haben wir die beckenkapazität
nicht auch die ärztliche Kapazität nicht
pflegerisch genauso also es würde an
allen Ecken mangeln von daher sind wir
auf die kleinen Häuser ringsherum
angewiesen auf einem Fachgebiet ist die
kleine Klinik mit ihren rund 400
Mitarbeitern dann doch auf Augenhöhe mit
dem 5 mal größeren Haus in Cottbus als
Behandlungszentrum für den
Bewegungsapparat künstliche
Schultergelenke werden hier eingesetzt
dafür kommen Patienten sogar aus dem
Berliner Umland die Eingriffe werden gut
bezahlt so will man durch die
krankenhausreform kommen
wenn sie stellen uns nicht dagegen
sondern wir suchen die Chance oder die
die Nische die Lücke die diese
Krankenhausaufnahme auch lässt und das
ist natürlich die Profilierung ist sie
wissen es soll die Leistungsgruppen
geben es ist die Option als Fachklinik
sich zu entwickeln und diese Chance
wollen wir nutzen doch der Umstieg in
innovative Technik kostet viel Geld die
Klinikleitung halbierte dazu die
Bettenzahl und nutzte corona-hilfen nun
wird sogar in der Notaufnahme bei Bedarf
ein Facharzt dazu geschaltet per
Telemedizin
nicht so gut wir sind hier ist es mit
dem Schmerzen ganz starke Schmerzen am
Ende ist es eine Qualitätserhöhung und
gleichzeitig eine Kompensation von
knappen personalressen künftig wird
Telemedizin noch stärker genutzt so wie
in der Notaufnahme soll dann auch bei
Hausbesuchen der Rat von Fachärzten
eingeholt werden
Vernetzung und Profilierung so will das
Naemi wirklich Stift seinen Fortbestand
nicht nur sichern sondern sogar gestärkt
aus der krankenhausreform hervorgehen
Entscheidung getragen bei uns geht es
jetzt weiter mit die Heinz die
Preissteigerung hat sich im August nur
leicht abgeschwächt nach dem vorläufigen
Berechnungen der Statistischen
Bundesamtes ist der erhoffte deutlicher
Rückgang der Inflation ausgeblieben
Stefanie Barrett woran liegt es warum
wird Deutschland diese hohe Inflation
nicht los ja die Inflation in
Deutschland ist ja auf dem Rückzug doch
mit einer Ratte von 6,1 Prozent im
August bleibt es ganz offensichtlich an
eher langwieriger und holpriger Weg nach
unten besonders schwer wegen hierzulande
die zuletzt wieder stärker gestiegenen
Preise für Energie und Nahrungsmittel
die energie verteuerte sich im August im
Schnitt um 8,3% gegenüber dem
Vorjahresmonat auch Nahrungsmittel
bleiben mit einem durchschnittlichen
Anstieg von 9% teuer einzelne Produkte
wie Gemüse Brot und Zucker steigen sogar
weiterhin zweistellig Lebensmittel waren
in Deutschland Jahrzehnte lang so billig
wie fast nirgendwo in der EU das ändert
sich jetzt und wie es scheint müssen wir
uns daran gewöhnen und Energie ist so
teuer wie fast nirgendwo in der Welt vor
allem wegen hoher steuern und öko-
morgen gibt es dann die Daten für die
Inflation im Euroraum wie sieht es da
aus ja eigentlich nicht sehr viel besser
denn volkswirte erwarten auch im
Euroraum lediglich einen ganz leichten
Rückgang auf 5,1 Prozent in Spanien
bislang ja muss der Knabe in der EU ist
die Inflation im August sogar wieder
angezogen auf diese Gemengelage wird nun
die Europäische Zentralbank sehr genau
schauen und dabei könnte sie zum Schluss
kommen die Leitzinsen im September doch
noch mal erhöhen zu müssen um die
Inflation noch in den Griff zu bekommen
so drücken die steigenden Preise nicht
nur auf die Verbraucherstimmung auch der
DAX heute im Minus die Aussicht auf
steigende Zinsen kommt ja gar nicht gut
an Stefan vielen Dank
im US-Bundesstaat Florida ist Hurrican
idalia mit Windgeschwindigkeiten von
mehr als 200 Stundenkilometern auf Land
getroffen begleitet von einer Sturmflut
und großflächigen Überschwemmungen
entlang der Westküste waren zeitweise
200.000 Haushalte ohne Strom die
Behörden hatten eindringlich vor Sturm
und zum Teil Meter hohen Hochwasser
gewarnt und die Bevölkerung aufgerufen
Schutz zu suchen
internationale Ermittler darunter FBI
und BKA melden einen Erfolg im Kampf
gegen internationale Cyberkriminalität
sie haben ein besonders gefährliches
hacker-netzwerk namens crackbot
zerschlagen das seit 2008 mit
chart-programmen Unternehmen Behörden
und Privatpersonen attackierte denn
standene Schaden wird auf mehrere
hundert Millionen Euro geschätzt die
Hacke sollen inzwischen keinen Zugriff
mehr auf die Infizierten Computernetze
haben aber wer hinter crackboard steckt
ist bislang nicht bekannt
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 23 32 42 43 46 48 Superzahl 1 und
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
wer will schon gerne durch eine digitale
Kunstfigur ersetzt werden damit Ihnen
das nicht passiert streiken
Schauspielerinnen und Schauspieler in
Hollywood seit Mitte Juli seit Mai schon
sind die Drehbuchschreiber im Ausstand
die mehr Geld wollen und auch bessere
Regeln im Umgang mit künstlicher
Intelligenz das heißt für Filmfestivals
wie das in Venedig das heute beginnt
kaum Hollywood Weltstars kaum US
Hauptdarsteller auf dem roten Teppich
weniger Glitz und weniger Glamour es
heißt aber auch dass die besonders
scheinen können die sonst eher im
Schatten stehen Annette hilsenbeck ist
in Venedig
Herausfahren aus Venedig hinüber zum
Lido der vorgelagerten Insel auf der die
Filmfestspiele stattfinden zum 80 Mal
und bei denen diesem Jahr der Streik der
Hollywood-Schauspieler Spuren zeigt eine
Chance für das italienische Marine Drama
kommandante mit dem preisgekrönten Pia
Francesco fabino plötzlich als
Eröffnungsfilm im Mittelpunkt des
Interesses der eigentlich geplante
Hollywood Blockbuster challenges wurde
abgesagt Grund die
Hollywood-Schauspieler streiken immer
noch und machen auch keine Werbung für
ihre Filme
Siri Präsident Damien
ist lalaland zeigte sich solidarisch mit
denen die höhere Gagen und Regeln beim
Einsatz künstlicher Intelligenz fordern
Kunst hat einen Wert für sich selbst es
ist nicht nur ein Stück Inhalt dass man
in die Pipeline schmeißt wie Hollywood
gerne momentan sagt und Kunst nachhaltig
machen auch für die Leute die sie machen
das ist in den letzten zehn Jahren
ausgehöhlt worden
weniger Glamour und ohne Hollywood-Stars
der Festival direkte bemüht sich um
Optimismus
wir haben mehr Zuschauer mehr
kreditierungen als sonst die Leute
lassen sich nicht von der Abwesenheit
einiger großer Stars abschrecken sie
kommen trotzdem zum Festival was ein
Zeichen dafür ist dass es ein großes
Verlangen nach gutem Kino geht
immer tatsächlich wird die Premiere
einiger Filme im Wettbewerb schon im
Vorfeld mit Spannung erwartet
meist oh der Film über das Leben des
legendären Dirigenten und Komponisten
Leonard Bernstein ein Porträt seiner Ehe
seiner Beziehungen und natürlich seiner
Musik
Hollywood Star Bradley Cooper führt
Regie spielt die Hauptrolle und wird in
Venedig nicht anwesend sein
Oskar Preisträgerin Emma Stone spielt
den Pool things einer schwarzen
fantasy-komödie eine junge Frau die
wiederbelebt wird und die Welt neu und
ohne Konventionen entdeckt eine Frau auf
ihrem Weg in die Freiheit die Welt oder
gibt es nicht und mit die Theorie von
allem ist diesmal auch Deutschland
wieder im Wettbewerb vertreten
wäre mit erfolglos ein Schüler ist immer
nur so gut wie sein Lehrer ein Thriller
der 1962 in den Alpen spielt bei einem
internationalen Kongress ein Professor
verunglückt tödlich und Ermittler
entdecken ein dröhnendes Geheimnis
23 Filme stellen sich im Wettbewerb bis
zum 9 September im Rennen um den
Goldenen Löwen für den besten Film
ja viel zu gucken auch jetzt hier im
Fernsehen gestern wurde der russische
söldnerchef bregorien heimlich still und
leise begraben seit heute können die
Russen Abschied nehmen von dem Mann den
viele in Russland als Helden verehren
das auslandsjournal nach uns hat
jedenfalls glühender Anhänger und
Nationalisten getroffen und nimmt uns
jetzt gleich mit nach St Petersburg und
um 0:30 Uhr gibt's dann unsere heutigen
Update mit Christopher Wehrmann von uns
allen hier auch den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hinter den Kameras ein
angenehmer Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter zunächst ein
kurzer Blick auf die Meere ihre
Oberflächentemperatur ist immer noch so
hoch wie nie zuvor aktuell liegt der
Durchschnitt bei 21,1 grad das hat
folgenden ein warmes Mittelmeer kann der
Treibstoffe Extremwetter auch bei uns
sein die Luftmasse nimmt diese
Feuchtigkeit auf und wärmere Luft kann
mehr Feuchtigkeit halten steigt sie auf
erreicht sie eine Höhe bei der die
feuchte zu Tröpfchen kondensiert es
bildet sich eine Cumuluswolke die sich
weiterentwickelt während der
Wolkenbildung wird gespeicherte Wärme
freigesetzt und die Wolke wächst weiter
zu einer mächtigen Gewitterwolke zu
einem Bus je wärmer und feuchter die
Luft desto mehr Wärme wird innerhalb der
Wolke freigesetzt und umso heftiger das
Gewitter
und diese Mechanismen gelten
selbstverständlich auch bei Wirbelsturm
wie zum Beispiel beim Hurricane Italia
was heute Nachmittag Landgang hatte wir
schauen bei uns aufs Wetter und da haben
wir es auch mit Schauern und Gewittern
zu tun einmal quer über Deutschlands von
Nord nach Süd und das ganze wandert nach
Osten und nach Norden und schwächt sich
im Laufe der Nacht ab die Temperaturen
liegen dann bei 13 bis 7 Grad morgen
startet in der Mitte erst einmal
trockener will sich hier Schauer und
teilweise auch Gewitter ja und ganz im
Südwesten da ist es eher sonniger
Temperaturen dazu bei 17 bis 23 Grad und
auch am Freitag haben wir es in der
Mitte mit teils kräftigen schauen
Gewittern zu tun weil bis zu 26 Grad und
in den nächsten Tagen wird es sogar noch
wärmer Temperaturen bis 28 Grad ein
schön